We now have some sense of how we can make lighting calculations, not take an
incredible amount of time. In this lesson, we're going to take an extremely high
level view of how objects get rendered by a graphics accelerator. This graphics
hardware is usually called the GPU, for graphics processing unit. A GPU uses a
rendering process called rasterization or scan conversion, which is optimized to
use the simplifications I've outlined. Let's look at one rendering pipeline from
end to end. The idea of a pipeline is to treat each object separately. The first
step is simply that the application sends objects to the GPU. What objects?
Typically, 3D triangles. Each triangle is defined by the full locations of its
three points. An application converts a cube into just a few triangles. A sphere
gets turned into a bunch of triangles. So, in the first step, the application
decides what triangles to send down the pipeline. In the second stage of the
pipeline, these triangles are modified by the camera's view of the world along
with whatever modelling transform is applied. A modelling transform is a way to
modify the location, orientation and even the size of a part. For example, if
you were rendering a bouncing ball, the ball's modeling transform each frame,
would move the ball to a different location along it's path. The effect of the
camera view is clear enough. After the object is moved to it's location for the
frame, is it still in view of the camera? That is, is the object inside the view
frustum. If not, then we're done with this object, since it won't affect any
pixels on the screen. In this case, we say the object is fully clipped. So here,
this cube is fully clipped since its outside of the view frustum. The camera and
modelling transforms compute the location of each triangle on the screen. If the
triangle is partially or fully inside the frustum, the three points of the
triangle on the screen are then used in a process called rasterization. If a
triangle is slightly off the screen, it gets clipped and it's turned into more
triangles. This process identifies all the pixels whose centers are inside the
triangle. In other words, it fills in the triangle. So, rasterization here has
found that this triangle covers the pixel centers, in these various places.
These locations are then used to show the image of the triangle on the screen.